(intro music)
- Hello.
- Hi.
- So we both have kids named River.
- I heard that.
- [Kelly] Mine's a girl, yours is a boy.
16?
- That's so nice.
Yep, he'll be 16 in June.
- So wait, so do you let
him drive you around?
Does that make you nervous?
- You know what's funny,
cause he's a city kid.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause we live in New York, and um.
- Oh, that's right, so
like probably a subway kid.
- Subway kid, and bike kid,
and he has not even asked me
about getting his license.
- Is that not so different
from when we were kids?
- Yeah, 'cause with teenager
driving equals freedom.
- That's what I say.
- Yeah.
But he hasn't even asked
about it, isn't that crazy?
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- I mean, kind of great for the planet,
ride that subway, okay.
- I know, exactly,
they're just like too cool for
school about everything, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He's like, "I don't need
that, I don't need that."
- [Kelly] Oh, man.
- I know, but it's kind of, yeah.
- I just remember it, yeah,
I felt like it was freedom.
I got my own job, I felt independent.
- [Keri] Yep.
- But I guess they already feel that,
like a kid growing up
in the city like that,
they probably feel so independent,
'cause taking the railways by themselves,
you know what I'm saying?
That's probably a different level.
- Everything is accessible
to them in a different way.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You can walk everywhere, you can,
you know, get City Bikes.
- [Kelly] Yeah, he's like
who cares, who needs a car.
- A little bit, yeah.
- And they're costly, so
great for you. (laughing)
- I know, perfect for me so far.
- And insurance sucks
when they're that age.
- Oh my God, yeah, yeah.
- Well, do you remember
how you learned to drive?
- Well, I was trying to think about that.
And I think I was--
- [Kelly] Where were you living?
- In Florida, on the Mickey Mouse Club.
(audience clapping)
- Oh that's right, that's right,
you were in the Mickey Mouse Club.
- Yeah I was, with all those kids.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I think I would
just drive around there,
like back woods, like
areas to the set, oh.
- [Kelly] This is adorable.
- Oh, wow, wowzies.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Oh, my word.
- Throw back Thursday.
- Pretending I can sing, which I can't.
- [Kelly] Whatever, (laughing) were you?
- That's fake, that's
fake, false advertising.
- [Kelly] When you say all
the kids, were you there when,
'cause I remember whenever I came up
I found out it was like
Justin, Christina, Britney.
- Yeah.
- Brian Gos, they were
all in that club together.
- It's true.
- I was poor, I'm gonna
be honest with you.
I only had the basic eight channels.
- I didn't have Disney channel, either.
- [Kelly] Okay, I never saw it.
- Yeah.
- So I never, I was too poor.
- But like were y'all
all in the same crew?
- Yeah, so they were
like the really famous.
- That's a lot of
massively talented people
all in one place.
- They were all very talented.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like the Christina, and Britney,
and Ryan Gosling, and
Justin, all those kids.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Were 12 when I was 17,
so I was a little older.
- You were the cool one.
- I mean, I could drive,
I was cool.
- Yeah.
- And then, but they were
wildly talented, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And two of my best
girlfriends, Lindsay and Alana,
were on the show with me, too.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- They were more my age, yeah.
- I have to bring this up,
'cause I think it's funny.
- Okay.
- You were in another club,
I was in this club, too,
Girl Scouts, you were a Brownie?
- I was kind of one.
- [Kelly] Okay.
But I heard that you got kicked out.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, so I think when--
- Who gets kicked out? (laughing)
- Only the coolest people, obviously.
(Kelly laughing)
When I was little,
so you're only like
five or six in Brownies.
- In your Brownies, yeah.
- And so I don't think they officially
call it just kicked out,
they're not that hardcore.
- [Kelly] Hardcore. (laughing)
- But.
- You're just not
welcomed back. (giggling)
(audience laughing)
- But me and my best friend
Jamie Valentine, in Arizona,
I think we were just
being too rambunctious.
And I think the story on the street
is that they told our moms
that we weren't invited back.
- Oh my gosh.
- We weren't Brownie material,
I don't know what to say.
We loved it, I hold it dear,
I think that's pretty cool.
- I got kicked outta Sunday school once.
- What'd you do?
(audience laughing)
- Here's the thing.
My friend Mary, whatever,
my friend Mary and I,
I was like, I don't know
if I should say this.
- Yeah.
- But we were laughing at something else.
- [Keri] It happens.
- In the Sunday school, and
you know when you're a kid.
- And you can't stop
- You just can't stop.
And the Sunday school teacher
was very sensitive in the first place.
- Yeah.
- And probably shouldn't have been
a youth leader in general.
- A youth leader, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- This was not her forte.
- No.
- And so we laughed,
and then we tried to stop.
Like I'm so respectful, but
I could not stop laughing.
- [Keri] And it makes it worse.
- And then we got kicked out,
and then I was like "Oh my God,
"who gets kicked outta
Sunday School?" (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Cool people.
- Yeah.
I was like, I know I felt bad,
I think about her to this day.
I feel bad about it, but I,
once you start laughing,
it's hard to stop.
- It's such a good release though.
Those are so, it's amazing.
- Exactly, and then you're like,
you're laughing even more
'cause you're supposed to stop.
- Yeah, um-hm.
- [Kelly] And you're a
jerk, you're in puberty.
- Yep, it's called church laughing.
- Like it's, yeah, it was not a good time.
(audience cheering)
So that was a look at her
new movie, "Cocaine Bear."
(audience cheering)
This movie is inspired by a true story,
which I did not know.
- That's the craziest part, yes, yes.
- Have you ever looked up
what they call this bear?
Pablo Escobear. (giggling)
- Yeah, I have, which is amazing.
(Kelly laughing)
I know.
- Which I just thought was hysterical.
- And it's like a stuffed--
- It's a real bear.
- It's like a tourist attraction.
- Yes.
- People go visit this bear.
- Yeah, so wait, so how
much actually happened?
- So the drug drop gone awry did happen,
in the Appalachian forest.
And a bear did find it, a bear did eat,
consume a massive amount of cocaine,
and then eventually the bear died.
- Aww.
- In our movie, what Liz is doing,
is basically it's the bear's revenge.
Like if the bear ate it,
and then takes revenge
on all the people who come upon it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, this is amazing.
Do you remember "Cujo"?
- Yes, I do.
- Like, remember that movie?
Okay, I loved Cujo. (laughing)
- It's kind of like that.
- Terrified me.
- Yeah.
- So I was like, this
is like a bear version.
- It's a bear Cujo, yeah.
- I'm very into it, yeah.
All right, well tell us about
your character in the movie.
- Oh, brother.
Okay, I'm a mom in Cocaine Bear,
and basically a drug run goes bad,
and it's like a Scooby-Doo
movie, basically.
Everyone's coming to find
the goods in the forest.
And, oh, oh.
Look at us.
- There you are.
- Oh, look at us. (laughing)
- [Kelly] I like it.
Someone is injured, and
you're having to carry them,
that's not good.
- That's my daughter.
- [Kelly] That's not good.
- And my daughter goes into the forest
to like ditch school with her pal,
and I have to go find her.
The drug dealers are
coming to find the drugs.
Cops are coming to find
the drug dealers, and.
- [Kelly] The bear is there.
- Adventure ensues with a bear on attack.
- I love this kind of film.
- Yeah.
It's wacky, and it's
fun, and when Liz Banks
called me to do it, we were
on the phone during Covid
talking about something
completely different.
And she called me back
the next day and said,
"Hey, you wanna read this
crazy film I'm directing?"
And I was like, "It's
about what?" (laughing)
- When I saw the ad, the bulletin,
like when you're driving,
I was like, "Cocaine Bear," what?
- [Keri] Like they really made this movie.
- But then I googled, and I was like,
"Oh my God, it's a real
thing that happened."
- For real.
- I think that you should make the movie.
- The real story is beyond,
like, you can't even,
it goes, first of all, Matthew
has a small part in it,
he plays the drug runner.
It's like the best few minutes
of the movie. (laughing)
The real guy, when the drugs went down,
and his plane, he died actually,
his karate instructor was
also on the plane with him.
Like the details just
get weirder, and weirder.
You can't even put.
- You feel like you're
making it up for a movie,
but it's real.
- You can't, yeah.
So Liz told me about the movie,
and it was during Covid,
and everything was so
intense during Covid.
Like the whole world was so intense.
- Yeah.
- And I just thought this is exactly
when we should make this movie.
- Oh, my God, I love the escapism of it.
- Pure escapism, pure fun, just go.
- And I love in the woods.
- Laugh.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I love anything
like that, that's awesome.
- Some laughs.
- I love survival stuff, too.
- Yeah.
- Do you think you would
survive in the woods?
If you were like dropped,
how do you think you'd do?
How are you in those situations?
- Would I survive in the woods?
I mean, you know, it's funny.
What makes you scared,
and what makes you panic?
Like if it's something with my kids,
I feel like I can rise to the occasion,
and be like, "I can handle this."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, like one time during Covid,
we were up in the mountains,
and staying in a friend's house,
and a bat, at night, it was bath time,
getting all the kids down
and a bat flew into the house,
and everyone was like. (yelling)
Aah, rabies, everyone's gonna die!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was like, "Everyone
in your rooms," you know.
And then I was calm
enough to get the bat out,
like open the window, turn off the lights,
and get the bat out.
But I think there are other
things I panic about, like.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Really gross snakes, or something.
I don't wanna be around a snake,
I don't wanna swim with a snake,
I don't wanna see a snake around swimming.
- Who wants to swim with a snake?
- No one. (laughing)
- No one.
- I'm not afraid of snakes,
but I don't want it to like be on me.
- No.
- Yeah.
- But some people do.
- Yeah, not me.
- Not me.